autre exigence mills à lucio qui est une
femme de 52 ans mère de 14 enfants
condamnée à mort elle a obtenu un sursis
à deux jours de son exécution ça devait
avoir lieu demain pour en parler en juin
valérie beaudouin et les chercheurs en
résidence à l'observatoire sur les
états-unis à l'uqam bonjour madame
beaudoin bonjour alors mille solutions
c'est vraiment le quotid des inégalités
face au système judiciaire aux
etats-unis où est tout à fait qui
provient d'un milieu défavorisé qui a
connu de la violence et la violence
physique sexuelle émotionnel c'est ce
qu'on mentionne qu'il ya eu par le passé
des démêlés avec la justice possiblement
bref un cas de personnes qui avaient pas
les moyens de se défendre et qui a été
reconnu coupable dans des circonstances
sont qui sont assez disons début l'os d
inquiétante et qui grâce à de la
pression autant médiatique politique de
vedettes comme même des crimes création
de ce monde vedette la télé réalité vont
eu assez de visibilité pour se rendre à
cette étape là et avoir ses sourcils
comme vous l'avez mentionné alors vous
dites qu'elle était déclaré coupable
elle a aussi été condamné à mort pour le
meurtre de son enfant en 2007 sa petite
fille c'est ce qu'on lui reprochait et
ses deux soeurs qu'elle était déclaré
coupable oui tout à fait parce qu'elles
vont à l'époque en 2007 elle était
enceinte d'imaginer deux jumeaux et sa
fille de 200 donc qui avait qui avait
déboulé les escaliers quelques jours
avant son décès et après on l'accuse en
raison des conclusions sur son corps en
raison des marques bon qu'on dit de
violence on accuse la mère de famille de
l'avoir tué on la questionne pendant
cinq heures elle répond à 100 reprises à
plus de cent reprises son innocence donc
qu'elle n'a rien fait à sa fille et
après toutes ces heures
d'interrogatoire elle dit mais je
suppose que je les fais et on le sait
vous avez couvert beaucoup plus de
procès que moi là qui est qu'après des
heures comme ça car quelqu'un n'a pas
nécessairement les moyens les outils
peut dire qu'elle est innocente parce
que justement il ya de l'acharnement
c'est le premier élément est là toujours
à prayssas clamé son innocence et il ya
vraiment des lacunes dans ce dossier là
parce que ses enfants on a interdit
qu'il témoin au procès n'ont jamais
accuser leur mère de violences physiques
on ne cache aussi le dossier médical la
fillette qui aurait pu expliquer les
conclusions tous les éléments de la
chute un point tel que non seulement je
vous disais les médias et des élus
veulent justement qu'elle soit une santé
mais aussi cinq membres du jury dont et
l'ont condamné à mort qui disent bien
finalement si on m'avait présenté
certains éléments ma décision aurait été
une autre alors il ya la culpabilité
aussi de ses membres du jury acquis qui
font tout en leur pouvoir pour faire la
même pression oui alors soit déjà cet
étonnant les jurés ce qui est aussi
étonnant c'est cette société appuie
bipartisans c'est rare quand même que
les républicains les démocrates
s'unissent pour demander qu'on surseoit
à une exécution oui et au texan je pense
que je peux les compter sur les doigts
de la main le nombre de dossiers on
s'entend mais deux côtés ce qui est
particulier c'est qu'il ya des
républicains a qui ont dit haut et fort
qu'ils espéraient que kylie kylie est
sûre si l'heure de cette exécution il y
en a même qui a dégoûté je suis je crois
plus réduire la peine de mort je
souhaite justement que des gens
coupables soient exécutés c'est mon
souhait mais dans ce dossier là il ya
clairement quelque chose qui a été
négligé est ce qu'on vous souhaite avoir
une personne innocente et qui est
exécutée donc une mère de famille
vraiment il y avait toute cette pression
la politique y est finalement une cour
d'appel qui a tranché en disant oui il
va suspendre l'exécution est ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va se référer à une
cour inférieure pour vérifier plusieurs
éléments et entre autres est ce qu'on
est cachée de la preuve est ce que la
preuve qui n'a pas été présenté qui
aurait pu l'innocent après est-ce qu'on
a présenté une preuve qu'ils étaient
frauduleux aux sinistrés dans les
allégations à des avocats qui défendent
l'accusé est ce possible les avancées
scientifiques dans plusieurs dossiers
envoie c'est ce que met les avancées
scientifiques d'aujourd'hui pourrait
prouver son innocence ou est-ce que son
innocence ont carrément ce qu'elle était
innocent à l'époque de son procès et
qu'on a pris une mauvaise décision est
vraiment tout ce qui va être à regarder
avant de suggérer un nouveau procès même
si les étapes il nous reste peu de temps
valérie beaudouin mais qu'est ce que
c'est la prochaine étape c'est après un
nouveau procès ou oui on doit on doit
évaluer tout d'abord donc on doit
évaluer les différents éléments il ya
une recommandation qui va se faire d'une
cour inférieure à la cour d'appel qui
eux apprécieront des deux derniers mots
pour décider ou non s'il y aura ce
nouveau procès mais je voudrais qu avec
les éléments le conviennent mentionné
qu'ils vont être présentés à mon avis
j'ai pas une boule de cristal mais je
crois fort bien là qu'il y aura un
nouveau procès pour cette femme là qui
est qui dans le couloir de la mort
depuis avait plutôt montré oui une reste
quelques secondes mais on entend quand
même assez rarement parler des femmes
qui sont condamnés à mort il y en a peu
alors oui j'ai regardé les chiffres ne
sont comptabilisés imaginé depuis
1608 alors on met en avant la formation
des états unis on est avant
l'indépendance
on dit que 103 4 % d exécuter à mort qui
sont des femmes c'est très rare ça
serait la première femme et latino
américaine est révisée qui toute
exigence et la dernière femme exécutée
aux exemples c'était en 2014 on s'est
quand même assez qui est extrêmement
rare on verra le biais sont pour la
suite des choses alors on suit ça et on
vous remercie valérie beaudouin pour vos
explications se traitent leur merci et
bonne vision
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit